es gibt ja mehrere fragen die man sich
stellt wie laufen in ein szenario rhein
wo wir eventuell tatsächlich kein gas
mehr haben in ausreichendem maß in
diesem winter und vielleicht sogar im
nächsten winter je nachdem wie lange
diese krise dauert und es ist auch
absehbar wir werden nicht nur in der
industrie schwierigkeiten haben
arbeitsplätze sind in gefahr sondern
eben auch sag ich mal es steht zu
befürchten dass auch heizung abgestellt
werden müssen im ernstfall wenn eben
wirklich kein gas mehr in ausreichendem
maß da ist und da stellt man sich
natürlich die frage warum haben wir
trotzdem so ein klein klein in der
energiepolitik und ich frage mich auch
wie unser bundeswirtschaftsminister habe
sich hinstellen kann und sagen kann ja
wir wollen auf keinen fall die
atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen lassen wir
wollen auf keinen fall gas fördern in
deutschland was wir dringend brauchen
wir haben gas für 30 jahre muss doch
endlich mal schluss sein mit diesen
denkverboten und wir müssen dorthin
kommen zu den lösungen und da würde ich
sagen fracking stadt frieren ganz klar
[Musik]